soon to be home to hundreds of ukrainian
refugees a tent village installed at an
irish army base after the country
officially ran out of state
accommodation the taoiseach or prime
minister at least partly blames the
british government's rwanda deportation
scheme and he wasn't holding back that
policy announcement which i thought was
a
wrong policy announcement by the uk like
a shocking sort of initiative in my view
to be doing some agreement with rwanda
clearly may have
motivated people
utilizing the common travel area
to come into the republic yes i think
it is one of a number of factors
ngos dealing with the crisis appear to
back the tisha cup the suggestion that
people are to be moved to rwanda that is
having an effect and it's having an
effect of
moving or directing people
to ireland who would have gone to other
countries
we asked the home office for its
response to the irish criticism but a
spokesperson declined to comment
ukrainians are now being forced to stay
at an old terminal building at dublin
airport the new arrivals didn't want to
go on camera but they told us how at
least a couple of hundred ukrainians
spent the night at this airport building
behind us there weren't enough
mattresses or air beds to go around for
that number so many spent the night
sleeping in a chair
some even slept on the bare floor
of course space was already at a premium
ireland has taken in 41 000 ukrainians
already and many have been staying in
places like sports halls like this one
in county waterford is it okay living in
a sports hall
it's like an unusual um
it's like
unusual experience to live in there you
know
but
we're just happy that we are
we are safe
the tents too may be safe but they're
far from ideal the irish government no
matter who it blames for the mess says
it's working intensively on an interim
plan to find more housing
stephen murphy sky news in dublin